now as we mentioned ukraine's government
say at least 40 civilians have been
killed in the latest series of russian
bombardments let's get the the latest uh
situation more broadly on the ground in
ukraine with retired air vice marshal
sean bell sean great to see you as
always let's start with a broad uh
snapshot of of where we stand here in
the war uh at this stage yeah well it's
day 144 key milestone today is really
the russians to declare the end of this
operational pause shouldn't be a great
surprise it was inevitable it's going to
end eventually it is quite a surprise
it's only 10 days long because that
hasn't been enough time to regenerate
combat power for the russians but
inevitably there's a compromise with all
of these decisions because every day
that the russians are pausing it gives
time for the ukrainians to dig in to
prepare the ground and also the russians
lose momentum which is so difficult at
times to gain and then maintain in
warfare um what we are going to see know
this renewed offensive we're going to
see the continued artillery barrage and
then troop movements severesque and
bahamut are likely to be the first
priorities here and then once they're um
fall it'll be across just a vance and
kramatorsk but a very animated situation
on the ground and if we kind of step
back and look at
all of the
land that russia has seized across
ukraine how do we frame this is this a
success for them so far are they on the
path to an overall victory or how would
you frame it well
we've generally been looking at ukraine
resistance and the tenacity of their
defensive forces but the harsh reality
is this red area has been expanding
steadily over the last few weeks and
months
if ukraine is to turn the tide the
western weapons as your previous
correspondent talked about are going to
be key to this it's not just about
getting the equipment to the front line
and getting the the soldiers trained
it's also just the logistics involved
and i use an example that the russians
have used 20 000 rounds of ammunition
yesterday uh each of those rounds weighs
about 50 kilograms that's about a
million kilograms per day of artillery
that the west is going to have to move
in to support any ukrainian offensive
that takes time and will take weeks
rather than days
in the meantime the ukrainian strategy
clearly is to try to slow stem the
russian advance to buy themselves time
the russians are also an occupying force
they've occupied quite a large area that
spreads them quite thin and what's
pretty clear as well is the rush the
ukrainians are making putting pressure
on the far northwest in kharkiv also
pressure on cursing because that forces
the russians they don't want to see a
breakthrough by ukrainians so do they
divert more manpower to stem those
advances in kharkiv or kersen but if
they do that then that dilutes their
main effort around the donbass region
which they clearly won't want to do
whatever it is very clear that the next
chapter of this devastating war in the
donbass has has commenced and it's not
clear at the moment how or when it's
going to end sean as always thanks so
much